blasting in from the atlantic storm
barra hit the southwestern coast of
ireland with raw power gusts of more
than 80 miles per hour sparking red
warnings in several counties that means
a threat to life
fishing boats hurried for shelter this
was shot by the skipper of the dawn ross
as he battled into port and castletown
bear in county cork well the conditions
weren't very bad there's the worst
conditions i've seen here in about 20
years
they're very very bad there's a day and
i normally get gail so one now but it's
very very poor the other day
and that's why there's so many boats
sheltering here a lot of water boats and
shelton spanish bush and everything
coming on there you know there's a lot
of boats up in boundary bay dodging as
well the bad weather
at the fastness lighthouse off the court
coast gusts of
97.5 miles per hour were recorded this
video taken by a technician stranded
there by the storm
we came out and got
us
caught here in the storm so we'll be
here for another few days
usually we avoid this kind of situation
but
unfortunately we're here now and
[Music]
these storm force winds have been
battering the coastline of counties cork
and kerry since about six o'clock this
morning and are forecast to last right
into tonight and into tomorrow
the winds have had an immediate impact
here in terms of power cuts and
localized flooding
tens of thousands of homes and
businesses lost electricity as trees
took down power lines water was lost
elsewhere and transport affected by
flooding
but most people seem to heed warnings to
stay away from the water to the relief
of rescue crews
for one one split second if you if you
if you drop your guard
you you could be
standing on a cliff edge and that wind
is enough to to
throw a person off balance
um
it's it's just it can be very
unpredictable it can take you by
surprise the the sea is a very
unforgiving place
it's a punishing storm but so far
without fatalities but it's also a
slow-moving storm and the message from
authorities is simple
barra hasn't finished with ireland just
yet
stephen murphy sky news in west cork